for those of you who were worried that
we wouldn't be seen another Avengers
movie for a very long time in the MCU
well there's no more reason to worry
today we have reports about Avengers 5
however it does come with a catch how's
it going everybody it's Warren and the
MC was and is a massive success ending
the Infinity Saga with Avengers in game
which is now officially the
highest-grossing movie of all time the
Infinity saga is something that took a
lot of work and a lot of time to build
up ten years so what comes next for the
MCU when is the next avengers endgame
level type of movie coming well like I
said today we have reports that Avengers
5 may only be just a few years away but
there is a catch and I'll go over that
in this video
reminder I'm still doing my Xbox one and
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so today
we're lucky enough to get two different
reports that actually connect to each
other the first report is that the next
Avengers movie Avengers 5 could be
coming to us in 2023 however these
reports also say that the next Avengers
movie could be a lot smaller in scale
which makes perfect sense because we're
not just going to get an Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame level
event and then Marvel turn right around
and try to outdo them it's not possible
infinity war and in game took years to
build up the characters and the story
arcs all took a lot of time so there's
no way that we can expect the next
Avengers movie to be on the level of
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame and luckily for us this was
confirmed by cinema blend cinema blend
Calm recently had an interview with a
vendor's in-game producer Tran Tran
who's contributed to the MCU in one way
or another ever since the very beginning
well luckily for us in this interview
she revealed when we can expect to see
the next Avengers infinity war and
endgame level type of events here's what
she had to say in her interview with
cinema blend calm and I quote our focus
right now is to make sure that the
titles we've released in phase four
obviously those stories are going to be
new exciting different and could connect
with the audience like the other movies
have been over ten years ago it's always
been our dream to get to infinity war
in game level we didn't know obviously
where that was going to go at the start
of the studio but it's incredible to
know that we were able to accomplish
that now it'd be amazing if we could get
to that level ten years later so I think
it's a dream to continue doing that and
build upon the MCU and the connective
tissue that we have and now with
obviously art Disney plus site and the
shows and how our characters are
venturing into that world and how that's
going to lead to the future and more
franchises and more stories and more
properties and their connective tissue
to the rest of the MCU it would be
amazing to do something like this
ten years later end quote so an
executive producer for Marvel Trent rant
has revealed that the next Avengers
in-game level type of event is not going
to be till ten years later and this ten
years later isn't even set in stone
it's her saying that it would be amazing
if the MCU could build up to the next
Avengers in-game level event in ten
years so although this doesn't really
confirm when we're going to get that
next major crossover event it does
confirm that it is going to happen and
everything is going to build up to it
but as far as the next Avengers film
goes Avengers 5 it is going to be
different than infinity war and endgame
it's going to be more like the first
Avengers film and Avengers age of Ultron
it's going to be a smaller team that is
most likely built up over phase four and
phase five it'll most likely have
characters like Doctor Strange
spider-man Captain Marvel black panther
at the Scarlet Witch and new characters
being introduced as well such as
shang-chi and possibly the Eternals so
although we can't expect to see another
Avengers movie within the next few years
don't expect it to be like infinity war
or endgame expect it to be more like the
original Avengers and Avengers age of
Ultron as for the next major crossover
event you can expect there to be just a
ton of characters in this movie because
the next huge event can't just match
what Avengers infinity war and what
Avengers in game did it has to be better
fans are going to expect more which
means they're going to have to put even
more characters into it which shouldn't
be that difficult because now we have
the x-men and the Fantastic Four to use
in the MCU there are so many characters
and so many storylines that they can use
for this next big crossover event so
things are definitely going to be
extremely exciting in the end
see you over the next 10 years for MC
you fans we can expect a couple of
Avengers films to come out over the next
10 years that ultimately lead up to the
next Avengers endgame level type of
event and then when we finally do get to
that event it's going to be absolutely
insane so let me know what you think
about this news will you be happy with
getting a couple of Avengers movies and
then finally getting that ultimate big
crossover event and 10-years be sure to
let me know in the comments down below
also don't forget to give this video a
like and subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date with the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for your chance to win
an Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof